stay down and hold your ears how I hear  your beautiful voice stop being adorable  and get down lock on coordinates for  three point one six five four seven fire  now  Nataly don't you worry  this thing isn't at all  we were in the wind we're going to trash  battling we're going down now dying  through the keyhole Scott recharge big  you dive small then you emerge big do  all my neighbors you got much flavor  sis's I'll be doing let's go you watch  steal me the crown and all your dreams  come true respect power banana but I  know delicious uh Castle Houska what the  heck is rock Leone pizza that's it I'm  done  congratulations San Francisco you've  ruined beats up somebody talk to me what  is happening  you